[Applause]
it's all taking these
[Music]
oh yes Donald Trump is now officially
the drunk at the end of the bar bitching
about football and you know this this is
the world that we live in now the
stupidest [ __ ] alive says something
so something ignorant every three days
and we have to debate it this Justin the
president has just tweeted that dogs are
gay and Chinese people spit in the
laundry disgust America so Oh Jay
Simpson is getting out of jail next week
and he's a football player that Trump
likes cuz he never took a knee couple of
heads but never a knee
spend 23 years folks get over that no
I've got an idea let's tell Trump that
there are lots of black people kneeling
in Puerto Rico maybe he'll get focused
on that very sensitive about this
because you know they're saying the
relief efforts they're a disaster which
is very unfair he's tweeting as hard as
he can no he will get on it as soon as
he finds out that they speak Spanish and
can come here anytime they like then
Trump says of course he cares about
Puerto Rico cuz he's from New York no
he's gonna head down there to Puerto
Rico as soon as someone from his cabinet
frees up a plane this week we learned
that the Trump administration is gonna
make America great again but not if they
have to fly commercial you can't do it
that way and today just a few hours ago
we lost another one another resignation
from the administration one of many Tom
Price the [ __ ] private jets this
after the Treasury Secretary memory
Steve minuchin took the Air Force jet
down to Fort Knox so his trophy wife
could take a selfie with the goal and
then the Secretary of the Interior he
needed a private jet to go up to Vegas
and all of them use the same excuse you
know that their cabinet secretary
business so urgent like their SEAL Team
six you know we've got a Code Red here
in Cleveland I got to get a housing
secretary here yesterday you know it
takes a lot of jet fuel to drain the
swamp ladies and gentlemen
and they're gonna drain that it's right
they're gonna drain the Treasury first
and then they're gonna get around to
dredging this swamp
these guys these guys should be
sentenced to fly on Spirit Airlines
forever in the middle seat in the last
row by the toilets the one that doesn't
recline in between an obese guy and a
baby with an ear infection now have you
been following what happened this week
down in Alabama George Roy Moore won the
Republican primary there he is
there look at that boy the [ __ ]
pistol yes he pulls out pistols yet paid
rallies he believes gay people should be
jailed he thought 9/11 was God's
punishment for sodomy and abortion he is
what is known in Alabama as a moderate
and well I thought I thought Mike Pence
was tough on homosexuality uh
this man says homosexual behavior is a
crime against nature and inherent evil
an act so heinous he says it defies
one's ability to describe it so we can't
expect him to be caught at a highway
rest stop men's room
[Music]
[Applause]
homosexual sex defies the ability to
describe I two people have sex except
they're both guys and it's in the but I
think I did it
speaking of getting a [ __ ] up the ass
Trump unveiled his tax plan speaking of
getting [ __ ] up the ass Trump
unveiled his tax plan you see unveiled
its still pretty veiled that tax plan
what he says here's what we know about
it for Trump it's terrific its
revolutionary it's gonna make jobs start
pouring into our country it's gonna make
the economy take off like a rocket he
said all these things boy I tell you
this guy the wall the health care bill
bringing the mining jobs back he's
always over selling isn't he it's always
over selling it with Trump and then it's
always a giant letdown he's like the guy
who gets the woman into bed by promising
her an orgasm like she has never had
before and then he comes puttin on the
condom